Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up on today's episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, we are looking at two more ways to maximize your brilliance and to help your vibrancy shine to yourself and to
those around you to help you on this career of yours and to, you know, help you be the best you can be along the way. I am Dr. Marianne Trent. We are fast approaching application season, which we're expecting, certainly for clinical psychology to open sometime close to the start of September. But the Clearinghouse do sometimes like to throw spanners in the works. So don't worry, I'll be here with you every step of the way. And I'll be here for free as well with the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, but also with the free Compassionate Q&A series too. You can join me on Monday, the 4th of September 2023 at 6pm. You can also join me on Tuesday, the 3rd of October 2023 at 6pm. And for the final time in application series this year
you can also catch me Tuesday the 7th of November 2023 at 6pm live across all of my socials Dr Marianne Trent feel free to just watch Soak Up The Goodness listen to me answer other people's questions or pop along and ask me your questions as well. And if you'd welcome some more support during application season or just generally in your development, do consider checking out the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month as well. Right, let's have a look at the first of our tips for today. So the first is something that I found really useful during the pandemic. So at that time, I was working in the NHS, but also working in private practice, also being a mother and trying to homeschool. And so there was quite a
lot of stress going on. At that time, even leaving the house felt really like you were dicing with the possibility of death it really felt very difficult so going out and working in the NHS whilst going shopping and trying to run a household and trying to manage my two children under a not particularly massive roof was a real struggle and so one of the things that I found really helpful was to take some time in the mornings before everything started. So for me, my sort of mindfulness and stress reducing practices took the form of 10 minutes of yoga each morning. So there's a brilliant program that you can access for not that much money called Yoga Burn run by a lady called Zoe and so the first one in the series you watch three times so I would do on a Monday morning a Wednesday morning and a Friday morning and then there's a really nice sort of
stretchy cool down one on a Sunday and so the next week you'd then do series two on a Monday, Wednesday and Friday and then do the the nice stretchy relaxing one on a Sunday and I think it lasted about eight weeks and so it was a really nice way for me to spend a little bit of time being mindful, checking in with my body, seeing how it felt but also enjoying the sort of calm and stillness of my house before it all got rowdy and it all got busy. And there were demands placed upon me to do things, to give more, to do, do, do, do, do, either for my clients or for my children or for my husband for that matter, you know. So yeah, is there a space in your day where you could reclaim some time for yourself to be mindful, to connect with your body, maybe to do some yoga? And if you're listening to this and you're like, oh no, I don't think yoga's
for me, have you tried it? Have you tried it? So yoga bone isn't traditional yoga, it's quite flowy, and it aims to get your heart rates up a little bit as well. But it certainly does help with your with your flexibility to and with your strength. So for me, I found that it was a really nice chance to just do 10 minutes of something because we haven't always got time in our days, especially when you're feeling really busy and squashed, to do half an hour, to do an hour, to do 90 minutes. But for me, I could find, you know, 10 minutes, four times a week. So I hope you will find that to be useful. It might just be that you do some progressive muscle relaxation before bed. It might just be that you do some
soothing rhythm breathing, something that is about you creating some calm in what might feel like chaos. Let's take a quick moment here to take a little break and I'll be back along very soon with the next of Marianne Summer soundbite tips. that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Welcome back. So in the first half, we were looking at ways to carve out space for you to be mindful, for you to connect, calm and engage with your body and find some tranquility,
some, you know, some some still calm space for yourself it's so important and it's still something I do so when I go for runs I like that sense I'm not talking to anybody I'm just alone with my thoughts there's no there's no expectation that I'll do anything other than keep my feet moving and you know connect to the sounds of nature and I do also do a little bit of litter picking as I'm out and about it's called plogging which is when you jog but then you in between bins you pick up some litter and then pop it in the bin on your way past so So yes, could you plug? Join my revolution of plugging, pluggers. So the next of my top tips is thinking about your caseload. And if you hold a
caseload of clients that you see for therapy or even therapy groups or, you know, any kind of work that you do within the team, anything that might be on your job plan, you can kind of think about as your caseload. You know, who are those clients? If you're supervising staff, you can think about them as being on your job plan and potentially on your caseload as well. If we've got lots and lots of super demanding or super risky clients, then that can really take its toll on us. So a really useful conversation to have in supervision or in line management, if that's a separate service or function for you, is thinking about balancing your caseload. So thinking about
when you're picking up new work actually I already have you know five complex cases um you know and this one sounds a little bit more simple could I put myself forward for this one and thinking about the importance of doing that and knowing that it's okay to do that and I guess it's similar to um one of the other um things of being boundary but it's it's it's more than that because you're literally looking at caseload management you're looking at well full up you're feeling right now you know whereas when you first took on the cases maybe you were more resilient maybe you were more well resourced or maybe it's the other way around you know when you first joined the team or when you first took on this caseload, maybe you're already feeling more full up. But now you're more into your stride or you're in a better place with your relationship or your course or training or your masters or, you know, your peers or your family.
You now feel like you've got some more flexibility, some more space in your window of tolerance to be able to step that up a little bit. So it's a fluid process, I would say, that changes from day to day, week to week. But it's important that you're checking in with that, with your supervisor and with yourself. You know, if you find yourself dreading a particular client or a particular day because of the combination of clients or tasks that you've got could you look at that could you jiggle clients around to different days to spread a bit of the joy or a bit of the misery but of the things that you find useful engaging or depleting throughout the week and yeah just make sure you're looking after yourself because if you're not looking after yourself then you can't help to put those oxygen masks on other people hope you found today's episode useful i will be
back along with the next episode of the aspiring psychologist podcast from 6am on monday if you've got any ideas for what you would like to be covered in future episodes, do come and let me know by connecting with me on socials. I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere, or you can slip into the Aspiring Psychologist community free Facebook group and tell me there, or even drop it in the YouTube comments. Please do like, subscribe, share, tell your friends about us, and I'll look forward to catching up with you very soon take care if you're looking to become a psychologist
then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.